your microphone's all good are you guys
happy with that I'm fine with it I'm
good if you're good I know I love it
I love it all right ready one two three
everyone Welcome to our news news
podcast your good news on the go today
we're covering everything from a Netflix
show about how to build a sex room to a
national debate about how to wash your
armpits and what yeah find out if you're
doing great well please welcome my
co-pilot of my dreams Rossi Ross Matthew
yeah hello I just want to say I think I
am washing my armpits correctly but
we'll get to that down the line we're
gonna find out Rob yeah well we're gonna
go there we're talking about anything
all the quirky fun inspiring and yes
deep informative stories that exist in
the world because well that's what we
need right now Drew well then should we
get right into it they hit me what do we
got all right Story number one Netflix
how to build a Sex Room Okay Ross well
don't even ask no I don't have one no
and nobody's shocked well you just got
married and you just bought a new house
yeah so Netflix might just have the show
for you it could transform your home and
your sex life in one felt swoops it's
like a show about how to design
and custom build a sex room in your home
Rossi thought well congratulations to
everybody who's building one I think
that that's great and I'm really I'm
happy for you and your libido you know
what I needed a sex room I needed a
blackout curtain and a light switch that
I just needed to be dark you know I
don't need anything fancy my fetish is
gratitude Drew I don't need anything
else if my fetish was gratitude I would
be gasming in a corner 24 7. because you
are full of breath by the way you're
welcome for that you are I I don't have
one of those secret fetishes that I have
a locker where I need a key to keep it
you know what I'm saying like when you
if you opened in your mind no not even I
swear wait are you PG in the brain I'm
PG on the streets and in the sheets
are you are you like a little um I think
you are I can see about you oh I'm a
dirty bird really I think so yeah but
just like corners of my mind where I
never will tell and they're it's just
for me and um but I don't think
I like I can understand certain kinky
things listen I've tried everything you
really huh I've tried ever thing that's
why I'm so boring now so so you just
have said yes and were you surprised
that there was anything that you were
like into you thought oh there's no way
I could be into that and you're like oh
you know I it's like I don't know if I
was into it or not I just wanted to try
everything I think that's fun and
exhausting
do you have anything any like a room in
your house you're like I'm not using
that right now it's just you know the
Christmas decorations are in there maybe
I could turn it into my own little
dungeon I don't I don't think I want a
sex friend I know I don't want to sex
through like I'm fine in the bed Mish
position
ha
ha
ha
ever called it that before no oh my God
a copyright she owns it wow that that my
sex ran I miss you is this yeah those
days are long gone yeah and I I you used
a keyword exhausting exhausting but back
when I was younger it I had all the
energy in the world yeah but now no no
well congrats like I said
congratulations to the people who want
this I'm glad you you're having that
kind of fun congratulations to the
executive at Netflix who came up with
this show I'm sure it will have an
audience yeah I I'm not going to build
this room but I will watch this show I
totally agree you're also like a
designer juice so I mean would you take
this gig would you design a Sex Room
you know if I was tasked with designing
a sex room I would avoid all the cliches
there wouldn't be like a lick of velvet
like no no red satin sheets no I like I
think that's probably also why I don't
want a sex hermist I don't like the way
they look yeah how would yours look it
would look like a CB2 showroom like it'd
be like in Barrel too then that's cp2 it
would be like white walls with like
that's not good in a sex room I just
want to put that out there like a black
like structure and like an awesome big
phallic marble something oh God and like
maybe a plant
you'd put a succulent in the sex room
I want a sanitizing station can I get
one of those right in the middle totally
like I I want the like instead of like a
love swing for there to be like a black
metal dim Demi loon that goes very
Alexander Calder rather than you know
and a demi Loom is a it's like a half
circle oh cute yeah like so picture like
a half circle coming down from a black
chain and like that's what you would
grip onto oh God but it could be
designed by Calder okay uh I don't want
to go in your room either I'm good but I
support you
um well okay Story number two I'm really
interested in your thoughts in this and
everybody who may or may not be out
there listening because when I first
heard about it I think I misunderstood
what it was but let's get into it so the
New Yorker is calling a new dating app
called field f-e-e-l D and it's for the
emotionally mature so like if you like
straight up honesty about your interests
Allah I want a sex room
um or I'm into X or I don't like why I
suppose this app is for you
um apparently like I think feet or sexy
like came with this story as an option
to discuss when I heard emotionally
mature dating app I got so excited
because my big problem with dating apps
is the bull and the Chit Chat that leads
to nowhere so I didn't know that
emotionally mature also was like a code
for fetishists yeah that wasn't clear to
me either I thought well emotionally
immature people on dating apps is
something that I don't think really
exists out there in the world but I will
say people saying what they want is on
dating apps I joined when I was single
when I was single I joined one of the
ones that the people joined right for
just a few days Tinder mm-hmm no I got
on grinder the other ones yes okay so
and the things it was for a day and it
wasn't for me it was like I did because
people do tell you what they want on
those apps I got sometimes not even with
words it was just a picture of what they
wanted oh my god really yeah wait a
minute yeah wait a minute because I'm
I've only ever been on one dating app in
my life like the the high the like the
um yeah the respectable one the tomato
tomato that would be a more grown-up one
I think because it's professional it's
not grown up no I I think it's
it's safer for people in a certain field
because they are they literally they'll
kick you off if you like screenshot
something oh that's good so like I'm
looking I want like a doberman on my ass
okay like with rabies who's ready to
pounce I am shocked you can send
pictures yeah so you could rather saying
hi you can just be like here is my
genitalia
well there's a house hi oh oh well how
you make a good point sir
stupid but there should be one that
there should be dating apps that are
based around interest right like
priorities you know what if there was a
dating out that was all about people who
loved interior design or spending you
know Sundays at farmers markets or you
know we can really fine tune them now
I'm hot I'm telling I know what you like
what about this one a dating app for
people who like getting stains out
I'll have what she's having yeah
um I got so excited to hear emotionally
mature and now all of my excitement is
gone because apparently it's a bunch of
people saying let's do three sons and I
want feet all this stuff that is not
emotionally mature to me that's fetishes
and being honest and that's okay and
there should be a dating app for that
totally but why are they calling it for
the emotionally mature that's such a a
mislead well I think they're trying to
connect it this way like it you you are
emotionally mature enough to know what
you're interested in and to say it out
loud and ask for it and okay I kind of
get that what would be the sexiest thing
that someone could send you on a dating
app well we talked about that dating app
I got really excited
um I'm not on it but I'm glad it's out
there called Farmers Only
[Laughter]
silver singles by the way I'm about to
be eligible for silver singles how crazy
is that it's that's cute because I like
you with an older person well I actually
oh my God maybe I should be fishing on
Silver singles it's too because I really
want a I want an emotionally mature
partner honestly nothing would make me
happier than filling out a silver single
profile with you let's do it okay all
right well we have to take a quick break
the next story up I'm really excited
about because apparently there is a
right and there is a wrong and there's
some Hot Tips do's and don'ts about how
we're supposed to be washing our armpits
we'll be right back
[Music]
and we're back okay so there are
apparently two ways to wash your armpits
according to Apple news there's a right
and a wrong way to wash your armpits
before I tell you Rossi how do you do
dem piss uh okay well I I clean my body
like I'm prepping for surgery you know
what I mean like I do it's like by the
way do you do that before and after sex
too I think unless it's like sprung up
on you I think it's you know I feel like
I've lost all ability to be spontaneous
I know right if it starts so long I
don't know I'd be like wait it's like I
feel like about sex the way I do getting
out of the house I still need to do like
50 more things
you'll get to it eventually yeah
um well I know I just I don't like a
Fufu thing you know I mean like those
body washes that are too smelly I like
an antibacterial soap I like to froth it
up and get it all just get myself
pristine are you sure you were not
tipped off to this no I swear to God
what we don't discuss the stories before
ever what because apparently Rossi ding
you are in the right category really yes
you are checking the Box because
apparently if you're an own a tour
person or like you know
anti-anti anything
anti-anti anti-anti anything yeah like
you know you don't want any chemicals
and you're one of those hippies that's
you know fill in the blank Drew
Barrymore yeah exactly I'm like like me
you got your Dr Bronner soap
apparently there is bacteria that can
grow under your armpits due to life
sweat friction material you name it and
an antibacterial soap is the way to go
oh oh oh I was right oh I didn't know if
you are a dirty hippie yeah um like me
and you don't rock
um anti-bacterial although I use Dial
soap that's what I use the orange bar
yes the best the best I am so twins who
knew that's cute well I also use Dr
Bronner's and that is like devoid of any
chemicals whatsoever they say that
throwing in a little apple cider vinegar
will do the trick
and if you're if you're rocking Dr
Bronner's you're probably rocking brags
too so don't even play like you don't
have some in the fridge so you take
apple what are you a vinaigrette
I'm not doing it apple cider vinegar no
no I I love the bar soap I know but for
those who you know are on the skin deep
app and fussing over every little detail
get yourself some apple cider vinegar
all right here is our next story Ross
are you a fan of fried chicken are you
such a fan that you would buy Colonel
Sanders home okay so I do love KFC and I
remember when I was a little boy my
Grandpa would get me KFC when I was a
really good kid you know and I love the
sides more than the chicken me too oh
and by the way if you can find a gravy
that's better than KFC then I'd like to
see it because I don't believe it I
don't believe it either and the only way
I would go rent this house or buy this
house if the pool was filled with that
gravy and all the pillows were the
biscuits you know I know that's it and
the coleslaw and the mashed potatoes
you're right I like the sides even more
than the product well it turns out Rossi
that the Sanders historic home located
in Shelby Kentucky
um hence the Kentucky Fried Chicken I
was happy to hear that detail that is
actually in Kentucky that he didn't live
somewhere else like yeah Arizona yes
um so this home includes his wife
Claudia Sanders Dinner House restaurant
and one of a kind KFC memorabilia would
you go stay there are you two chicken
um I don't know but I'm this is all over
the news right now and I also just like
knowing that Colonel Sanders is a real
man like was a legit person yes like an
Orville Redenbacher they existed they
were there 100 like I believe in Ronald
McDonald I believe in these people and
so to know that they were alive well and
it's not a caricature but an actual
human I it I buy into that yeah why does
that make you feel better like you like
that but like the fact that there's not
a real Dairy Queen makes you not want to
go there it I just like um here's a fun
fact when Ray Kroc was developing
McDonald's he would fly prop planes all
over these towns and he'd say wherever
you see the church steeple put a
McDonald's right there because then that
can be a family restaurant and it's a
town where people are congregating and
going to churches and that's the proper
location to find and those kind of
things just fascinate me in business you
know there's an interesting movie called
the founder did you ever see that about
with uh Michael Keaton Keaton and I
haven't and I need to and it sort of
tells the story of how he
um helped build and sort of took uh
McDonald's I just to read like Ray
crock's like manifestos that he would
write to his employees
um like I think when I look at the
newspaper I think the business section
is something that although I don't know
anything about NASDAQ or Wall Street
um and it's all like floating numbers to
me that section I think affects people's
lives more than we realize and so paying
attention to like business you know what
is Big Pharma doing today or what's
Google or what you know what is closing
what's opening these are going to lead
to like things that affect our life so
I'm always it's the business angle I
think it's I think it's interesting how
people approach business differently the
people who do follow like the NASDAQ and
I don't know what that is but or the
people who fly the plane over to see
where this church is to know that a
restaurant would do well there that's
the business I'm faster interested in
the NASDAQ I don't get
um and nobody wants me there
um okay our next story Barbie themed
home decor also known as Barbie core
could be your next interior design
Endeavor Apartment Therapy one of my
very favorites has released expert tips
for barbifying your interior of the home
but it doesn't have to you know go over
the top
Ott if you will it doesn't have to be
bubble gum pink walls you can add
scallops and Frills and dainty floral
prints in softer shades of pink or Peach
that's enough to give your home that
Barbie core Hue thoughts well all I the
only thing I ever wanted the Barbie had
besides Ken was the um let's be honest
was the um that the Malibu car remember
the dream car the skipper and yeah
that's her sister Skipper I think color
is everywhere Barbie is about to be
everywhere we've all been obsessing with
those pictures with Margot Robbie Ryan
Gosling as they've been filming the new
movie if you've been seeing being
directed by Greta Gerwig I can't wait I
think that's the movie that's sort of
being
um the most anticipated right now so I
think Barbie core is gonna explode upon
the release of the film
[Laughter]
so will a lot of other things right but
you know you're the reason why I started
using color in my house I am I always
was just white white white white and
then because of you I painted uh this
summer a bedroom and the sun room and
like really went there what color did
you paint your bedroom well none of the
colors in the Barbie house because of
pink bedroom even though it sort of was
like my childhood fantasy I went for a
really masculine bedroom we did it's
called crack pepper this color
you have me at Cracked Pepper you're
welcome paint color and the actual
Cracked Pepper or you want to know my um
the name we chose for the Navy yes it's
just called Dark Navy oh I love that
right I like that it was just straight
to the point it really clear I painted
your back wall dark Navy in your
dressing room that inspired the pick I
know so colors where it's at I love that
they're doing these soft colors Barbie's
having a moment right now like in the
zeit guy so this makes sense she really
is
um I'm glad that people are expressing
themselves more in their homes I think
we were going towards more of a
minimalist thing than the pandemic
happened now we're going back to
maximalist because our homes are where
we work entertain live and we're just
functioning differently than we did a
few years ago so I think your home is
the best place to express yourself quick
question you've been doing construction
update on that how is it it today is a
good day
um patch you talked to me two days ago I
probably would have told you why I've
hit rock bottom and uh but I found this
new company that's helping me I want to
preserve a lot of the plaster that I've
uncovered and I don't want to do drywall
um this is all about like a kitchen you
would find 50 years ago up in the
hillside of an Italian Village and
um that has nothing to do with drywall
understood it's tile and plaster so I'm
trying to do something very bizarre and
I'm kind of finding it as I go and it's
just been a show and I'm not gonna lie
every everybody has those moments where
you just think I don't deserve to you
know
think I have designed prowess whatsoever
um and then you just pick yourself up
and you keep going yeah I think anyone
that's ever done Renault or like a home
project or tried in any way to make
things beautiful there's this messy part
in between frustrating but it's worth it
in the end well I have been in that sag
um for quite some time and I'm finally
pulling myself out and very excited any
Barbie inspo in your kitchen not a
little understood
um alrighty everyone well follow the
Drew's news podcast wherever you get
your podcast and if you like the show
then you know you could tell a friend
like hey Rossi did you know that there's
a Drew's news podcast oh I must listen
And subscribe to that thanks Drew did
you know that there's a show called The
I can't even say it say it the Drew
Barrymore show that's right I love that
show and then you could tell your
friends and your co-workers and even the
gal you just met at the grocery store I
highly suggest pets they want to know if
you're on a dating app you can let them
know that this podcast is your interest
you could let anyone know that this
podcast is your fetish you can put us on
in your sex room
good option now that's the only way to
turn me on in your sex room is with a
remote control thank you
um well if you want more than just audio
pleasure be sure to watch the Drew
Barrymore show every weekday by going to
the drewberrymore show.com to find your
local time and channel for some reason
when there's a.com attached to it I feel
comfortable saying
um and as always we make this show for
you so take it with you
[Music]
great
[Applause]
[Music]